who lives in a sewage plant under the
sea or perhaps not because no one's
found anything that interesting under
the sea in Fallout 4 just a big
mysterious building and a little bit of
loot it's a shame because the map is
roughly 30% water but maybe we just
haven't found anything yet
the Boston wasteland depicted in
Bethesda's fallout 4 is garnished with
many secrets finding these crafted and
concealed gold nuggets are a satisfying
reward for the more adventurous
wasteland Wanderers more exciting
however is the moment when you stumble
upon something that the game's creators
may not have intended would be
discovered that's just what happened to
one fallout 4 player who while clearing
out a Raider camp fell into the vast sea
instead of running for sure this player
decided to explore equipped with the
power suit and my alert cakes which let
you breathe underwater this person went
on an expedition and found a mysterious
underwater structure the building in
question a large bronze structure that
seems to be some sort of pumping or
water filtration structure has a working
light but cannot be entered it kind of
makes you wonder what this place is
did Bethesda put it in just for fun
could it be a hint at some future
underwater content maybe it was
something that Bethesda was working on
but abandoned will we ever find out the
plot thickens if you think back to
November when someone found an unused
harpoon gun when fired a bubble
animation comes off the weapon and the
enemy suggesting Bethesda might have
been working on an underwater sequence
in fallout 4
Bioshock crossover probably not but a
girl can hope have you found anything
worthwhile under the sea let us know in
the comments I'm Kate you can find me on
Twitter and how not to draw and remember
to keep it GameSpot calm for all your
gaming news
[Music]